when University students take my courses
even Those Who start out knowing
virtually nothing about Russian history
they've usually heard of the romanovs
and the end of the family Dynasty during
the Russian Revolution
and usually what they know has to do
with the Princess Anastasia whom they've
discovered at the hands of two former
Walt Disney animators
the movie is a musical Adventure that
was actually made for 20th Century Fox
and is based on the legend that an
orphan princess escaped her family's
execution
it features the voices of the actors Meg
Ryan John Cusack Kelsey Grammer and
Angela Lansbury
and it made about 140 million dollars at
the box office
invariably a student will raise her hand
and ask is it true
right away I'll know what she's talking
about and I always feel badly when I
have to say no it's not
Anastasia the daughter of the Azar
Nicholas II and his wife Alexandra
didn't survive
neither did her parents three sisters or
brother
nor the loyal servants who were with
them
in spite of the tales spun by Hollywood
and some convincing Pretenders who kept
the tabloids busy for years
the last from Manoff Emperor and his
family were executed in Cold Blood a
century ago
in a Merchant's basement at the
provincial Russian town of the
katerinburg
today's lecture will tell the real story
of the Romanov Dynasty from its rise to
power in 1613 until its bloody end in
1918.
It's a drama that's so filled with
Adventure Intrigue romance and
heartbreak that you couldn't make it up
the groundwork for Romanov rule was laid
by the ruric dynasty of the 15th century
led by Yvonne the terrible the tsar of
all the Russians until his death in
1584.
the rurics reclaimed Russian sovereignty
from the Mongols
they oversawed the establishment of a
separate Russian Orthodox Church
built the Kremlin and expanded into
non-slavic lands to forge the Russian
Empire
Yvonne from the moment of this car
Nation claimed the title of Tsar
but he also precipitated a tumultuous
period known as the time of troubles
after he struck and killed his son and
heir
once Yvonne died his successors
maintained a semblance of order for
almost two decades
his younger son fyodor succeeded to the
throne in 1584 and ruled until his own
death in 1598.
but in name only
Fielder was intellectually incapacitated
and relied upon Regents to rule for him
the first was an uncle the second his
brother-in-law Boris good enough
when the child is fueled or died the
work line disappeared as well
hoping to maintain a period of relative
stability leading Nobles agreed that
Fielder's brother-in-law Maurice good
enough would succeed him as our
but then famine gripped Russia and
resentment against good enough escalated
a pretender posing as the dead Prince
Dimitri now invaded Russia from Poland
posing as Yvonne the Terrible's young
son who died years before in 1591 at the
age of nine
he was advancing on Moscow when good
enough died himself in 1605.
good enough's death facilitated the
false Dimitri's Ascension to power as
the news are
but peace and stability were not to be
the first false Dimitri was overthrown
and killed within a year
other claimants temporarily seize power
including a second false Dimitri
and Central Authority effectively fell
apart
polish forces temporarily occupied the
Kremlin
but by 1612 a Grassroots Army led by a
butcher and a noble one claimed the
Kremlin
and they vanquished the Nobles who'd
collaborated with the Polish Invaders
with both the polls and more than one
false Dimitri now out of the picture
and the ruric line extinguished the
pressing question was what next
at the start of 1613 a specially
convened assembly of the land the
Russian turn is zimski Sabor
decided the issue
consisting of about 500 Nobles called
boyars lesser Gentry clergy merchants
and even some peasants the zemski Sabor
selected as the news are the 16 year old
great nephew of Yvonne's beloved first
wife Anastasia
this was the young Mikhail Romanov who
had no strong personal connection to the
throne
he didn't even know his aunt
she died before he was born
on the other hand when we hired
romanov's father fyoder
had been a major political player in the
Kremlin until he'd run afoul of Paris
good enough
it's a bit complicated like a chain car
wreck on the interstate
after The Rook line died out she ordered
a Romanov and Boris good enough both
aspired to greater power
and when good enough gained the upper
hand he disposed of his rival
but instead of killing Fielder and
making him a martyr and a potential
source of sedition
good enough forced him to become a monk
good enough now also exiled the Romana
family including the very young Mikhail
then good enough died and fielder wrote
us to prominence in the Russian Orthodox
Church
now known as filaret he became the
Metropolitan of rostov
that is he rose to the Russian Orthodox
Church's position of highest
ecclesiastical Authority in the town of
rostov northeast of Moscow
but when the polls were driven out of
the Kremlin they took filler back to
Poland as their prisoner and he was
still in prison there when his son was
selected zar
Mikhail Romanov first balked at the idea
of assuming power
he and his mother had taken Refuge at a
monastery in castroma about 80 miles or
130 kilometers Northeast of rustov
he expressed no interest in the
intrigues at the Kremlin he was also
quite young and unrelated by blood to
the ruric line
but these were exactly the reasons why
the zemski Sabor selected him
he had no old scores to settle or Allies
to reward
and his aunt Anastasia the one he'd
never known
was still fondly remembered
over the greater part of the next two
decades Mikhail re-established the
social order and stability needed for
the country to move forwards
Mikhail died in 1645.
when he did his son and successor Alexei
achieved further advances
in 1649 Alex say presided over one of
the most momentous developments of his
31-year reign the establishment of a new
law code called the ulogenya
among other things the ulogenya
formalized the Russian system of serfdom
which tied the Russian peasantry to
minorial Estates
government record books were now
established to register the peasants
alexei's expansion of the state and the
power of the nobility elicited
resentment from those on the losing end
of the arrangements this prompted
numerous uprisings
the most significant was the stink of
rosin Rebellion on Russia's Southeastern
Frontier from 1670 to 1671.
it's named for a Cossack leader who'd
grown up at a time when runaway surfs
were escaping to settle in Cossack
settlements
rosin led a band of these landless
migrants who profitably raided existing
settlements and some of the tsar's
Fortress cities
many peasants gladly conspired with
rosin against their Noble landlords
yet they did so while typically
expressing loyalty to the distance are
as they would right up until the 20th
century
rosin build himself as fighting against
the Nobles and four bizarre even when he
was marching against alexei's forces
so whatever else might be said about
this Rebellion which came with a full
complement of atrocities profiteering
and drunken orgies
it makes clear that the new ramanath
Dynasty inherited the peasantry's
traditional reverence and affection for
the Tsar
as the rightful ruler he was God's
divinely ordained representative
and commoners blamed their problems not
on him
but rather on the heavy-handed hand of
their Noble landlords
a Russian proverb captured this benign
view of the serf's highest authorities
this way
God is in the heavens and the Czar is
far away
in spite of rosin's friendly
proclamations Alex say was unpersuaded
so when rosin was at last captured in
Alex a had him quartered alive
this gruesome form of execution
symbolized the powerful Vengeance of the
crown
to be quartered meant that a condemned
person's arms and legs were tied to four
different horses
the men overseeing the execution sent
the horses off in four different
directions literally ripping the
prisoner apart
after this horrific death rousin's
dismembered body was thrown to the dogs
the message of stanka rosin's public
execution was clear
were the Czar to be challenged he was
determined to demonstrate his family's
Authority and vengeance
by the time alexay died in 1676 Romanov
rule was firmly established and now
Peter Romanov Peter the Great took the
crown
and transformed Russia into a great
European state
Peter realized something that other
European monarchs of the age already
knew
that is that the Manifest power of the
state needed to be more constantly
visible
so he in his 18th century Roman of
successors sought to demonstrate their
divinely ordained absolute power through
Baroque and Rococo art and architecture
from the time Peter the Great moved
Russia's capital to Saint Petersburg in
1703 the city became the main stage on
which the autocracy demonstrated its
culture influence and Power
at the same time
danger increasingly lurked there
Court Intrigue would topple three
different Emperors from 1741 until 1801.
and in the years to come it was in Saint
Petersburg that Russian revolutionaries
known as The Decemberists who came from
the upper class and Military
called in 1825 for the creation of a
free Russian State along with a federal
government and Constitution
it was there that a popular movement
known as The People's will adopted
terrorist practices and targeted and
killed the Roman of Tsar Alexander II in
1881.
and it was in the romanov's capital when
pushed to the brink by the upheavals of
the first world war a revolution
initiated by Angry hungry subjects would
finally topple the romanophotocracy in
1917.
each generation of romanovs sought to
lead in its own fashion
often recognizing the vulnerabilities of
the autocratic State and how the
backwardness of peasant Society Shackled
the economy
but each also understood the Goldilocks
dilemma of stolen porridge
too much reform was too hot and too
little was too cool
and it seemed they could never get it
just right
Alexander II undertook one of Russia's
single greatest reforms in his
emancipation Manifesto of 1861 that
ended serfdom on Russia's private
Estates
nearly two years before Abraham Lincoln
freed United States slaves
but after Alexander was murdered in the
streets of his own capital
his son and successor Alexander III
concluded this is what reform brings you
only reaction and repression came from
Alexander III
Vigor he went after the terrorist group
The People's will which had murdered his
father
in a few years the terrorists were all
executed imprisoned or driven into exile
Alexander also tightened censorship
ended University autonomy and expanded
the ability of the Russian police the
akrana to ruthlessly Target radicals and
revolutionaries
and he reasserted the power of the
autocracy in the church
he was promoting the cause of Elites at
the expense of workers and peasants
he was upholding the positions of ethnic
Russians at the expense of ethnic and
religious minorities
no one was in Greater awe of Alexander
III than his eldest son and Heir
Nicholas
and when Alexander III died in 1894 no
one was more terrified
in the hours after his father's death a
dejected Nicholas proclaimed
I'm not prepared to be czar
I don't even know how to talk to
ministers
he didn't share these misgivings
publicly though and they were nowhere on
display when he took the crown
an American journalist who covered the
Carnation marveled at the official
ceremonies seeing in them a
manifestation of The Emperor's power
another onlooker remarked that the site
made clear
that there was nothing equal on Earth to
the might of the Russian monarch
according to Columbia University
historian Richard Wortman in his book
scenarios of power myth and ceremony in
Russian monarchy
still clouds hung ominously over the
start of Nicholas II's reign
so that the Russian masses could express
adoration for the new Czar and gratitude
to the Romanov Dynasty a banquet was
arranged on kodinskaya field near Moscow
unfortunately larger than expected
crowds and poor planning led to a
Stampede in which
1389 Russians died
to make matters worse Nicholas and his
wife Alexandra didn't cancel the
subsequent coronation festivities and
balls
this was a typical misstep
the new czar's political instincts often
led him astray
and he was ill-suited to be an autocrat
he preferred spending time outside of
the Capitol with his wife their four
daughters and son Alex say to the dreary
business of ruling
perhaps there were moments in Russian
history when a ruler's failings wouldn't
have been so decisive
but the years of Nicholas's Reign were
some of the most turbulent in history
the country had finally started the
process of modernization and
industrialization
this gave Russia some of the highest
economic growth rates in the world
but the autocracy was unprepared and too
incompetent
to manage the transformation of Russian
Society
with the rapidly growing industrial
working class and dramatic rates of
urbanization
alongside continuing poverty and
oppression
revolutionary sentiment now made a
resurgence
new versions of old revolutionary
parties re-emerged and new groups like
the Bolsheviks grew out of the
Industrial Age
as social tensions and mass
impoverishment took a higher profile
Nicholas and his ministers decided to
initiate a war with Japan
the czar's minister of the Interior
confided
in order to hold back the tide of
Revolution we need a short Victorious
War
there was just one problem with this
plan
the Russians weren't in a position to
win the russo-japanese war of 1904 and
1905.
instead they suffered an embarrassing
loss
as a result the war aggravated social
and economic tensions
when earlier ramanov rulers had
previously faced such uprisings the
unrest traditionally occurred at the
periphery far from the center of
government power
not so in what became known as the
revolution of 1905.
now
more than ten thousand of Saint
petersburg's industrial workers and
printers went on strike
and on a Sunday morning in January 1905
thousands of these workers and their
families along with tens of thousands of
other Russian subjects proceeded to The
Winter Palace
led by an orthodox priest named father
gapong
the crowd was peaceful the people had
left the Revolutionary Banners at home
as they'd been instructed
they brought no arms only icons
they'd come to respectfully appeal to
the Tsar about what he might do to ease
their suffering
they consisted of men women and children
but as the people gathered at the narva
gates just outside the palace guards
opened fire
within minutes more than a hundred
people lay dead
hundreds more were injured in a tragedy
remembered as Bloody Sunday
tragic irony is that Nicholas II hadn't
been in Residence to receive the
people's petition
he was with his family in the historic
town of zarzkes yellow The tsar's
Village South of Saint Petersburg home
to the traditional summer residence
still in his absence the monarchs
carefully preserved image as the revered
and trusted little father of the Russian
masses
had died along with the petitioners on
Palace Square
the road to the Romanov Dynasty's
abdication was paved this January
morning
10 months later in October 1905 a
Cascade of mutinies protests and
rebellions culminated in a Country-Wide
strike now with Russia paralyzed Nichols
II agreed to a series of reforms known
as the October Manifesto
he promised to create a parliamentary
body called the state Duma and to Grant
amnesty for political prisoners
and he affirmed the people's right to
basic civil liberties
with this the revolution of 1905
promised a new age of constitutional
rule
but by Spring 1906
Nicholas had reclaimed some powers
he'd retained veto authority over the
state Duma making it unable to promote
legislation or past decrees that weren't
in keeping with his wishes
and even though political prisoners had
gained their freedom new political
opponents of the regime were taking
their place
violence increased rather than decreased
revolutionary terrorists went on the
offensive
in the first eight months of 1906
1782 terrorist attacks claimed more than
1300 lives
in response Nicholas's government
executed more than 3 000 people for
political crimes over the next five
years
clearly he faced Monumental public
challenges
but he also confronted private and
personal challenges the biggest was in
his own family
after years of praying for a son an heir
to the throne
Nicholas and Alexandra had celebrated
the birth of a son Alexei in 1904.
he was named in honor of the first boy
ever born to our reigning Romanov the
17th century Tsar Alexei
with his birth his parents believed that
the dynasty would continue
troubling signs appeared weeks later
when the infant started bleeding from
his navel
Alex say had hemophilia
without the medical interventions that
developed later in the century
hemophilia was a devastating
life-threatening condition
any bump bruise or scrape could prove
lethal
by the 1930s it would be discovered that
certain snake Venoms when diluted cause
blood to clot and in 1937 Harvard's
Physicians published a paper describing
anti-hemophilia globulin found in plasma
which could decrease clotting time
but for now
alexei's precarious metal medical
condition created the opening for the
notorious gregoria Rasputin to enter the
Romano Center Circle
and the annals of Russian history
czar's wife Alexandra made Rasputin's
acquaintance through the recommendation
of friends within St Petersburg Society
Rasputin himself was a peasant from
Siberia and a self-proclaimed healer and
holy man
his healing powers are questionable and
his claim to Holiness unwarranted
he was a charlatan who clamored after
power money and satisfaction of the most
carnal kind
but the romanovs persuaded that Rasputin
alone could heal and protect Alexei
became completely dependent upon him
Rasputin did produce a temporary remedy
like calming Alexei with some variant of
hypnosis
just enough to allow his body time to
heal
unfortunately Rasputin also used his
ingratiating capacity to ruthlessly
Advance his own material and political
positions he slept with Noble women and
prostitutes alike
he tore through the streets of the
Capitol and drunken in disorderly States
the romanovs kept alexei's vulnerable
medical condition carefully hidden
but they couldn't keep Rasputin's horrid
Behavior Under Wraps
his sexual orgies and depravities were
widely known and discussed
in the words of the historian Bruce
Lincoln
sensible Russians found it difficult to
retain even a modicum of respect for an
empress who allowed into her presence
a crude peasant whose outrageous
escapades were known to them all
so after the revolution of 1905 this
charlatan from Siberia sometimes known
as The Mad Monk irrevocably tarnished
whatever mystique and Charisma the
romanovs had retained
a few short years later in July 1914 the
murder of the Archduke Franz Ferdinand
and present-day Bosnia and Herzegovina
touched off the outbreak of World War
One
and the Russian people's patriotic
fervor and dynastic appreciation was
temporarily revived
one month after the archduke's
assassination Russia invaded what was
then East Prussia
but in five days of battle at tannenberg
in present-day Poland
German forces slaughtered Russian troops
only ten thousand out of a hundred and
fifty thousand Russian soldiers escaped
once the casualties mounted and the
Russian people processed the emotional
suffering and material deprivations of
the poorly run war effort
the Czar and his family were considered
undeserving of continued adoration and
support
in late 1916 a small group of
aristocrats tried to save the Romanov
Dynasty among them were a cousin to the
Tsar a conservative member of the Duma
and Prince Felix yusapov who was among
the richest men in the capital
all previous efforts to convince
Nicholas and Alexandra to get rid of
their disreputable advisor had failed
any official or minister with principles
enough to try to force Rasputin away
from the royal family usually fell from
Power himself
so now this conspiratorial group
believed that the only hope was to
murder Rasputin
late on the evening of December 16 1916
the conspirators lured Rasputin to the
Palace of the wealthy Prince yusapov
with the prospect of meeting the
prince's young wife in an intimate
setting
when Rasputin arrived the conspirators
told him that the princess was
temporarily delayed but they invited him
to partake of some cakes and wine
that were laced with copious amounts of
cyanide
as rasputinate and drank he seemed
impervious to the poison
determined to wait no longer usopov
excused himself and returned to the
pistol
the pr the prince shot the czar's
advisor at Point Blank Range
strange story of Gregory Rasputin wasn't
over yet however
as the conspirators celebrated Rasputin
Rose and staggered past them towards the
door
two more gunshots found their Mark in
The Mad Monk collapsed
among the conspirators was a doctor who
assured the others that their target was
finally dead they bound his hands and
pushed his body through a hole in the
ice of the nearby canal
and when his his body was discovered a
few days later Rasputin was dead at last
but an autopsy revealed that his lungs
were filled with water
the medical evidence suggested that he'd
survived the poisoning and the spray of
bullets and died only from drowning
the romanovs were inconsolable
but their own end was near as well
in March 1917 after a week of massive
protest Nichols II abdicated the throne
as the first revolution of 1917 reached
its crescendo
after almost 304 years in power the
Romano photocracy had come to an end
at least the family was still alive for
the moment
Nichols II found an element of relief
and even happiness after the first
revolution of 1917 and his abdication
relieved of the duties and pressures of
an office he was ill-suited for he
relished the days he spent at the
Catherine Palace in zarska solo with his
family
the first revolutionary government
called the provisional government
treated the deposed Monarch and his
family well this changed when a second
revolution led by Bolshevik radicals
established a new worker state
at this point the romanovs could feel
the hostility of their captors towards
them intensify and their treatment
deteriorated when opposition to the
Bolsheviks and their Soviet government
brought the country to a civil war
with the situation deteriorating the
Bolsheviks transferred the Romana family
first to tobolsk in Western Siberia and
then to the home of a former Merchant in
the Ural town of the katerinburg
the former Czar his wife and their
children along with some trusted
servants were now prisoners of the new
Bolshevik state
optimistically they awaited Freedom
presumed to come through a literal
King's Ransom arranged by one of their
relatives several were crowned heads of
Europe
but early on the morning of July 17 1917
family members were awoken with word
that there was fighting nearby
guards moved them to a basement room
telling them it would be safer there
instead once the family assembled armed
Bolsheviks walked in and pronounced
their death sentences
each executioner had a designated Target
to avoid any mistake
when the shooting stopped each of the
Romanos lay dead except for the air
Alexei and the third oldest daughter
Anastasia they were wounded but alive
now the guards finished them off
alexse died from two gunshots to the
Head
Anastasia was stabbed repeatedly with
bayonets
the bodies were doused with sulfuric
acid and buried in unmarked graves in an
isolated rural area
there they would remain for decades
although an amateur investigator
stumbled upon the scene in the 1970s he
remained quiet about his Discovery until
after the Soviet Union collapsed in 1991
with the archive sealed and the bodies
unaccounted for the mystery about the
final days of the Romanov Dynasty
persisted for more than seven decades